Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new avengers 5 video recently a lot of you been
asking me about this big announcement kevin feige
recently made about the final avengers film and a
bunch of news sites were framing what he said out
of context in a really weird way so i'll explain
what's actually going on with avengers 5 and just
the future of the avengers movies in general like
what kevin feige actually said in what he meant
by that if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i will be doing
marvel moon knight episodes soon and there's even
a report that we might be getting an extended
director's cut of spider-man no way home with a
bunch of extra scenes in a couple weeks so i'll do
videos for that too if they wind up releasing it
just give us more tobey maguire more andrew
garfield and more matt murdock daredevil
but recently you may have seen people posting
about the final avengers movie in all your feeds
news sites were claiming kevin feige said
avengers end game was the last avengers
movie and everybody was freaking out as you
would expect but the news sites were taking
what he said completely out of context this is the
actual clip of what kevin feige was talking about
marvel studios and the marvel cinematic universe
is now past their 10th anniversary and with the
release of the final avengers movie we finally
completed a 22 movie infinity saga that was from
the eternals movie bonus features and behind
the scenes kevin feige was explaining why
they chose to do the eternals movie after the
avengers infinity saga movies all the phase 1
phase 2 phase 3 movies where do we go from there
where do we start and what we really wanted to do
was two things start fresh with whole new
characters new story lines but actually go
back to some of the deepest richest mythology
in all of marvel comics he talks about wanting
to push into more cosmic stories that feel like
marvel like it feels like a marvel movie but have
a totally different vibe from the marvel movies
that came before during the infinity saga
and to do that they went back to classic jack
kirby eternals because the characters and the
stories are so weird and so cosmic in a way that
the traditional core marvel characters are not
if you go back and you read those old jack kirby
stories they just feel totally different from core
spider-man iron man avengers comics even thor who
is a cosmic character technically this is the rest
of that clip of kevin feige talking about that
he's called king kirby for a reason and he created
something many years ago called the eternals which
is one of the most mythologically rich story lines
in the history of marvel it really gives us a
rich canvas to play with so when he's calling
avengers end game the final avengers movie he's
really just talking about it in the context of
the final avengers movie in the infinity saga
like the book end of the infinity saga not the
last avengers movie that they will ever make he's
just talking about wanting to grow the toy bin of
characters and concepts that marvel plays with
in the movies to keep things from getting stale
that's why marvel phase 4 is the beginning of the
multiverse saga now we have the multiverse saga
through the loki episodes the new kang multiverse
war spiderman no way home with toby mcguire andrew
garfield coming back we all just saw the doctor
strange multiverse of madness trailer with a
multiverse illuminati team patrick stewart's
professor x coming back from the fox marvel movies
we should tell him the truth with the promise of
more x-men characters like deadpool coming into
the mcu soon marvel going way crazier way more
cosmic to grow the toy bin of characters and
set up a much crazier future for the avengers
movies the whole idea is how do they do better
than avengers end game avengers infinity war
like do you go bigger do you go weirder how
do you do something that feels even better than
avengers end game it's really hard to do in the
past avengers movies have been sort of bookends
to each different phase marvel phase one was
all about introducing us to the core characters
then they ended that by having them all team up
forming the avengers for the first time but also
at the same time setting up the infinity gauntlet
larger storyline and using avengers infinity war
avengers end game to end that arc with marvel
phase 3. so because it is so hard to follow
up an avengers movie after avengers end game
that's why kevin feige said a long time ago during
their initial comic con for marvel phase 4 that
they were not planning on having an avengers movie
during marvel phase 4. they were just giving it a
beat to rest marvel phase 4 in the multiverse saga
is setting up avengers secret wars more cosmic
avengers movies with way crazier twists like
having those fox marvel characters come back the
sony spider-man characters like andrew garfield
toby maguire coming back from different eras
and making all those things fit into the mcu canon
in a really easily relatable explainable way for
casual fans let us go talk to the professor mcavoy
or stuart these timelines are so confusing and it
just takes several years for them to do that and
also if you want any kind of confirmation that
kevin feige and marvel are working on avengers
5. one of the other top-level marvel producers
who also shows up in this same eternals movie
feature where kevin feige is talking about the
future of the mcu nate moore also spent a lot of
time talking about avengers 5 on the set of the
eternals movie while they were filming it a couple
years ago back during january 2020 that's how long
ago this was two years ago journalists went to the
set to talk to him about what was going on with
the eternals movie and while they were there
they asked him about future avengers movies
so keep in mind that this is him two years ago
talking about this but this is his quote about
avengers 5 he said we could build towards it or we
could just say here is a standalone avengers movie
and i think as long as the story was strong
and interesting enough people will come see
it we're kind of nerds so we like to build towards
things and we like to spread breadcrumbs to see
where they come but yeah i think the audiences
also kind of want to be surprised so to some
degree we don't want to say you saw that trick
let's do that trick again then he goes on to say
what's the new way to surprise people even when
we did an avengers movie what would be the funnest
version of that well we all just got done watching
the doctor strange multiverse of madness trailer
a billion times patrick stewart's professor x
coming back from the fox marvel movies mild shock
bringing a bunch of those other franchise
characters back through the multiverse is a really
fun way to put together another huge avengers saga
but the idea was that a couple years ago right
after avengers end game came out they were just
waiting a beat to try and figure out how they were
gonna plan the future of the avengers sagas cut
to two years later 2022 as i'm posting this video
they probably figured most of that out as we've
seen from some of these trailers with a lot of the
quote-unquote breadcrumbs that they lay like it is
pizza time o'clock inside the mcu now because of
the multiverse so like i said the whole idea here
is that marvel phase 4 was never supposed to have
an avengers movie book ending it like the other
phases so this break that they're taking between
avengers movies is about five or six years minimum
marvel's revealed the majority of all their movies
between now and 2024 meaning that 2025 would
be like the very earliest that avengers 5 could
happen which would put it about six years after
avengers end game we might even have to add an
extra year to that just because of all the delays
that happened the past two years no thanks to the
virus so maybe even seven years between avengers
movies oh my god just kill me now but because of
everything that's happening during the dr strange
multiverse of madness trailer everything that
happened during spider-man no way home i think
the whole idea is that they're slowly using
marvel phase four to re-integrate or integrate
the x-men characters fantastic four spider-man
characters from other sony franchises setting
the stage for a super weird secret wars saga down
the road through the avengers movies my early
theory right now just based on all the movies
they have coming out the next couple of years
is that captain america 4 will be like the next
mini avengers setup movie in the way the captain
america civil war was kind of like avengers 2.5
and during captain america 4 they'll reference
putting together a new team again they kind
of already started to do that in the shangshi
movie during the shangshit post-credits scene
the hulk bruce banner tells shengshi welcome to
the circus and then after that they discussed the
10 rings of power their cosmic origin guys stay
safe welcome to the circus wong welcomes them
to the team saying their lives will be forever
changed but none of the characters in these scenes
say the word avengers out loud you just have a
bunch of the avengers characters present for this
i think they did it that way mostly just to be
more subtle about the way they're putting the new
team's roster together like they don't want to pin
themselves into a corner right at the beginning
of marvel phase four but that's basically what
this conversation is about shengshi becoming part
of the quote unquote new team with all the other
avengers who are still alive after end game so the
new avengers roster will just take longer to come
together that's all i also just did an avengers 5
first look video for the special new avengers mcu
mural marvel did with a bunch of the characters
in their brand new costumes i'll link it below in
the description thank you very much to the person
who totally took a picture of it when you're not
supposed to take pictures of that hopefully they
didn't get fired right after this made it online
but hopefully that explains what's going on with
avengers 5 right now kevin feige wasn't saying
that they're never gonna do an avengers movie
again it's just that marvel is taking phase four
to play around with a bunch of new concepts really
weird stuff and bring a bunch of other stuff back
into the fold now that they own the rights to all
the fox marvel characters fantastic four x-men and
they figured out their new sharing deal with sony
for all the spider-man characters so now they're
doing toby mcguire andrew garfield stuff and
playing with a much larger group of characters
so they can tell way crazier stories even the
russos were talking about doing a secret war saga
when they were promoting avengers infinity war
back in 2017 i just did a bunch of doctor strange
multiverse of madness trailer videos you can click
here to watch those learn about all these x-men
that are coming back thank you very much patrick
stewart and you can click here for my brand new
moon knight trailer video from the super bowl
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!